com'è che hanno preso i tuoi genitori
quando quando gli ha detto che eri etero
insomma loro erano tranquilli no quand'è
che gliele detto al tuo amico guarda
senti sono etero ad oggi non
bisognerebbe più aspetta però anche
sugli uomini posso messo un po di tempo
prima perché avevo un po di timore per
il suo giudizio io credo che siamo tutti
un po ambiguo si fosse che la classica
frase da etero io ho visto persone che
davanti a un uomo una donna incinta
etero schifoso a etero di merda ma sarà
un problema della persona che magari
avete risposto solamente che si vedono
un sacco di ater in giro ultimamente
candolini etero persone eterosessuali in
giro non si sa da cosa è un significante
cioè ognuno ha la sua debolezza
tutti etero tutti quanti etero che vanno
in giro con le carrozzine per un giorno
che siamo più veloci
non so come un cane meglio alla nonna
domanda personale 6 etero gay gay o ve
lo spiego il mio figlio che un uomo una
donna hanno dei bambini cicogna
alla cicogna è il grande bluff degli
etero la cicogna io ho visto una bambina
a rotolarsi per terra alle 12 e m
implorare il papà e la mamma di portarla
a casa
ma perché potevamo fare quindi lei è
però normale io sì normale domanda un po
pungente hai amici etero ne conosci
se un paio se accettiamo in compagnia
però tante diciamo che non è facile
testimoniamo qualcosa di magico perché
queste due coppie si sono conosciute
nelle gran canarie da un tipico locale
di heather esiste in questo nel mondo
normale
l'amicizia fra uomo e uomo e voi siete
amici o siete in via di sviluppo ma gay
è facile organizzare che ne so la casa
arredare mentre tutto quanto carino una
coppia lesbica senza problema invece è
quella lì che ti cambia la ruota della
macchina o ti invita al suo barbecue in
una coppia etero
chi esce dalla casa chi fa il barbecue
da donna etero non sa anche un pochino
stanca di non saper guidare la macchina
cioè se diventassi normali in due
secondi il camion
vai non c'è una separazione dei ruoli
esce chi fa cosa e ed è una cosa assurda
ma tutto questo ragazzo che fa l'uomo
che fa la donna dalle altre cose
forse un po io un po su cosa sono
portate sempre avanti la normalità
raccomando ok